I I uh had a neighbor whose nephew
um
got involved in meth and he told he had
been to prison and he got out of prison
and when I met him the nephew had gotten
out of prison and I met him and was
talking to him and he was yeah I was I
was just got out of prison he said and
he told me he said when I tried crystal
meth for the first time as soon as I
tried it I realized that was the only
thing I ever wanted to do for the rest
of my life was more crystal meth and he
stole everything from his mom everything
was her grandma everything from his
uncle everything from all of his friends
ruined every relationship in San Diego
and then went to somewhere else San
Bernardino and made friends there and
stole from all them and then did that
all across the country until he finally
wound up in Texas and you know that's
where he finally got rolled up and sent
to prison but that that meth thing is
freaking crazy huh you know it's crazy
you know you know these drugs are crazy
these harder drugs like as you kind of
said he controls their whole life you
know and most of the labs are smaller we
call them mom and pop Labs or cooking
ounces that's cute you know you know
it's um they make enough to get their
own for free and you know and
sell a little bit to their friends you
know so they get theirs for free and you
know they're cooking in these houses
with these little kids you know when
everything is off-gassing into the you
know into the air and getting into the
carpet and walls and everything else so
we started bringing Child Protective
Services with us when we would do
methamphetamine lab warrants and and
they would bring the kids to the
hospital
and when they would test them you know
high percentage of them would test
positive for methamphetamine just
because the staff you know was in the
carpet in the atmosphere you know it
just breaks my heart you know me having
a daughter you know these little kids
involved and then Not only would they
get charged with the meth lab and
Manufacturing they would get charged
with child abuse from CPS also
so you would do these investigations
your your get are you getting human
intelligence that's telling you hey I
get my I get my meth from this person
over here then you find out where that
person lives then you track them for a
little while figure out you know where
they're doing suspicious activity and
then you do a hit on it how does that
work yes that's one of the means with an
informant hey you know
you know informants you know some are
trying to work off charges some are just
paid informants and they go around and
that's what they do you know so and so
is manufacturing meth here you know I've
saw you know these class wear items I
saw this part of the cooking procedure I
saw these chemicals you know and then
you do you know some more background and
then you do you know some investigations
surveillance and use kind of some of our
techniques that we use to you know kind
of make sure and validate the informant
and we also get information from
different places who sell these
chemicals you know Joe Blow is buying
you know keeps buying you know every
month so many pounds of red phosphorus
so many pounds of iodine crystals or the
different stores when you could buy the
coal pills the pseudoephedrine or
ephedrine tablets over the counter
they would kind of some stores would
work with us and they would get license
plates
so we do a work up and
um you know find out where these people
lived and started an investigation and
then we got enough
probable cause for a search warrant we
would hit these locations
you know because of the the dangers of
meth labs a lot of times you don't know
what the atmosphere was so you when you
rated it you would have to go in with
full
SCBA self-contained breathing apparatus
but you didn't know what the environment
and oxygen level was in the houses and
of course you got this big tank on your
back and it's
kind of cumbersome and a lot of the
local SWAT teams where Clan Lab trained
for tactics so there was little smaller
tactical bottles you could use so a lot
of unknowns and you know one of our
investigative techniques you go through
and garbage cans when they put it on the
curbs a lot of these
meth people that know that we would pull
trash so they would save every bit of
lab trash they ever had in one room
so you're missing you know you're
missing mixing acids and bases together
and things are off casting so it's not a
very safe environment to say the least